hello everyone and welcome to my
q a i'm answering questions today that
were submitted on the
in beta stage social media platform
think spot
which i had a hand in developing over
the last few years
as an alternative to patreon although
others have contributed far
more these answers were posted on
thinkspot before their release on
youtube
so if you want an earlier view of such
things you might consider checking out
the thinkspot platform
i've edited the questions a bit and
grouped some of them together
so i can address the broader topic i
hope you find this worthwhile and
interesting
i also hope to start live q and a's at
some point again in the future when i'm
healthier and sharper
i would like to know how to believe in
the divine
even though it is a loose end
i know without some sort of grounding
any hope about a positive future falls
down
could you please tell us how your
conception of god has changed in the
last year or two and
has your wife's burgeoning faith had an
impact on this conception
i was rather taken aback when you said
in your return home video posted five
months ago that
with the grace and mercy of god you
might be able to generate original
material once again
why do you think there are so many
people who are prone to just
following an ideology seemingly blindly
today especially in america and
maybe especially among younger people
why do people seem to cling to what a
doctor an organization or a political
stance or
what a news network or source says
seemingly religiously i'm not talking
about religious
religion specifically i don't think but
maybe what i seem to see as replacements
for faith or a good
family slash meaningful life etc
having listened to you for many years
now in this minor clergy
in the orthodox church my questions are
have you attended any services in the
eastern orthodox churches or
have you done an in-depth exploration of
eastern orthodox christianity
how do you respond to the idea that your
personal theology aligns so well
with what is taught by the eastern
orthodox
churches well i'm going to try to answer
all those questions at the same time
let's start with the third set
why do you think there are so many
people who are prone to just following
an ideology seemingly blindly today
especially in america and maybe
especially among younger people
why do people cling to what a doctor etc
says seemingly religiously
well i would say that
something has to be done with the
religious impulse
so and we could think about
what the religious impulse is critically
and deeply
for a minute
so imagine that you might consider
defining the religious impulse as
the consequence of the necessity of
having the highest
having a goal at the highest possible
level of
conceptualization and organization
psychological organization social
organization
we have goals on a daily basis and a
weekly basis and a monthly basis and
personal goals and familial goals and
social goals but
all of that has to be nested in the
broader
world of value let's say all of that has
to be nested within something like well
what is the ultimate goal what is the
final goal
underneath which all of those more
proximal goals are subsumed and
that becomes a religious question i
would say by definition
it's an impossible question to answer in
some sense because
to provide a definitive answer would
mean that we would have to possess the
classic attributes of god at least his
omniscience
to be able to finally answer well what
is it all for but we're still stuck with
the necessity of identifying
the highest level goal and
if and that's really that that the
identification of that goal
was exactly what our
traditional religious structures were
attempting to do
for better or worse and they did that
with practice and with
ritual and with drama and with symbolism
and with music and with art and
with literature with dance um all of
which are integrated in more
archaic communities let's say
those were all our attempts to orient
ourselves at the highest possible level
of being
perhaps we're all striving to be at
least in our more
noble moments we're trying to be good
people
ethically and to serve the good whatever
that might be and
it's the religious domain that strives
to answer those questions at the highest
possible
level of abstraction now if
you lack that answer if you're
divorced from a religious structure then
you have to find
a replacement somewhere because the
question
isn't going to go away the question
what's it all for
what should i orient myself toward or
what should i imitate or what should i
be in awe of
you're stuck with that or even in its
negative sense well what's the purpose
of life anyways and why bother
um and so that can lead you into a
very destructive nihilism and so
you're stuck with the problem
and if your culture hasn't provided you
with a solution
or you've rejected that solution or the
solution no longer seems tenable to you
maybe because
it's fallen prey to a rationalist
critique
that doesn't mean the problem goes away
you find a replacement for it
and for better for worse
now
the first of the set of questions i
grouped together will turn to it was
i would like to know how to believe in
the divine even though it's a loose end
well it is and it isn't
uh i'll answer that in relationship also
to could you please
tell us how your conception of god has
changed in the last year or two
well one thing i've been thinking about
lately is
the idea of thought as a dialectical
process so
imagine that
you posit a question in your imagination
your life presents you with the question
what should i do today
what would a person do what should a
person do in this situation what should
i do with my life what should i do with
this relationship and
answers appear in the theater of your
imagination
or doubts arise but something happens
you send out a call
essentially and you respond or something
in you responds with the generation of
an answer
or maybe multiple answers and in the
case of multiple answers
you can then undertake uh an argument in
your head that's the dialectical process
between
the two positions that might have
emerged
in the course of these revealed answers
so there's a revelatory element to
thought which is the appearance of
new information in the theater of your
imagination and then there's a
dialectical element which is the
combat between different revealed
thoughts
to evaluate them and rank order them in
terms of their credibility and
applicability
okay so now imagine that we have that
faculty we have the faculty for
revelation and we have the faculty for
for dialectical thought
now imagine that
you formulate in your imagination or
perhaps your culture helps you formulate
the image of an ideal being and that
might be god as such but it it also
might be say in
in the case of christianity with christ
or buddhism with buddha or
islam with muhammad the idea of a
person who's divine in some important
manner which brings the divinity down to
earth
in any case whether
the imaginary being
in the theater of your imagination is
purely divine
god himself or
you know incarnated in some sense in a
in a
human figure it enables you to
produce an avatar of your imagination
with whom you can converse and so you
could ask yourself well
you can ask yourself such questions is
as
if you're plagued by doubts about what
you should do in this situation is
well what would you do if you were
trying to do the best possible thing or
what would someone who was always
striving to do the best possible thing
do you formulate that question and you
might get an answer
that this is the proper pathway forward
now that doesn't mean
you'd be necessarily inclined to
implement that it might be too
difficult or maybe you even might doubt
that that's a
practical way forward but
not only can you produce avatars in your
imagination and then
use them as sources of revealed thought
but your culture can fill in the
attributes of that avatar so for example
if you're christian and you've been
taught about
the life of christ as it's portrayed in
the gospels
all those descriptions flesh out the
personality and then of course
the image of christ is reflected in
western culture in
a multitude of ways all of which
inform the structure of that internal
avatar and
which in principle flesh it out
so that it's
the potential source of revealed truth
in imagination
buttressed by all that cultural input
and so you would say well in some ways
that
avatar with whom you can converse
is now the internal embodiment
of all the ideas about what constitutes
the highest good
that our entire culture has been able to
create and communicate insofar as you've
been
exposed to that and are able to
understand it
and then so you could imagine that that
could be of substantial practical worth
regardless of the ontological reality
of that avatar of your imagination
but then i don't think that the
issue necessarily ends there because
you can then ask yourself well does that
imaginary avatar
share in any real being
and then you ask yourself well is there
anything real about
the hypothetical ideal and
it seems to me that there is something
real about the hypothetical
ideal we recognize its manifestation in
other people
and we're happy about that we're we're
inspired by that
we might be in awe of that we certainly
recognize it as a good thing
we're pleased when that manifests itself
in us
its manifestation in us certainly makes
us more attractive to other people
and also i would say of more use to
other people and
also more likely to be truthful and
perhaps
able to take care proper care of and
love other people
and i don't think any of that isn't real
and so that means that there's some
relationship between the imaginary
ideal and reality itself that's not
trivial and i don't know what that might
mean in the final analysis
you have a god in the imagination which
is our conception of god and
does that bear any relationship to
the real god or indicate that there is a
real god and
the answer to that is we don't know
i wouldn't dismiss the idea so rapidly
so
that's pretty much now there's something
else i guess
how do i respond to the idea that my
personal theology aligns so well with
what is taught by the eastern orthodox
churches
i don't really know that i don't know
how to respond to that idea because i
don't know
the theology of the eastern orthodox
churches that well
um i do know some thing about it
um i know that the eastern orthodox
churches stress the idea that the
fundamental
ethical responsibility of
the indiv the individual is to
become as christ-like as possible and
i think that that is the fundamental
ethical responsibility
basically by definition because
at minimum speaking psychologically
which is the safest way to speak about
such things
the figure of christ is the ideal avatar
of the good
in the western imagination um
and thus it's by definition that your
ethical obligation is to imitate that
in every way that's possible and
that's specified to some degree it means
to
treat being itself with love even your
enemies
to not wish them ill but to wish them
to wish the good for them as well
and to tell the truth and and to live
by the dictates of your conscience
and that that's the pathway to divinity
i think that's all true so
you know i was deeply influenced in my
thinking
as most of the people who are watching
this would know by carl jung and
he was certainly influenced by his
knowledge of the eastern orthodox
doctrine and so i've been influenced
by the eastern orthodox church via that
route
i think that there isn't any more
serious
question than your relationship to the
ideal
again virtually by definition and that
there isn't anything better that you
can do than attempt to embody that good
as fully as possible and
i've tried to make a practical case for
that i suppose and perhaps that's why
with respect for the idea and perhaps
that's why
so many people from the eastern orthodox
church in particular seem to
find resonance in my ideas
has my wife's burgeoning faith had an
impact on my conception of god well
some impact
tammy my wife has always taken the idea
of truth very seriously
her recent brush with death has
deepened her religious sense and
impelled her towards a life that's more
consciously focused on service to others
her family
in particular but not only her family
people beyond the family
and i also think that's a function to
some degree of
our stage of life she's a grandmother
now and
her children are grown and able to take
care of themselves and so she can turn
her attention to
other people maybe farther afield from
the immediate family
i'm watching what she's doing and
listening to her and
watching her practical application of
her faith and
that affects me just as everything she
does affects me because i watch what she
does and take it seriously
and her recent actions have indicated
she's had she's helped a number of
people
quite substantially uh in the recent
past
with a group that she's been
communicating with and all of that's
very
interesting to me she's showing me
i mean i've taken the idea of god
seriously for a very long time
and i've said on multiple occasions that
i try to act as though god exists and
that that's essentially my definition of
belief when people say do you believe in
god
belief is a multi-dimensional word and
the question one question is well what
do you mean by belief and for me
the proof of belief is to be found in
action and
i decided that i would act as if god
existed a long while back and
of course i'm imperfect in that uh
inevitably now she's doing that more
explicitly as well
not she wasn't doing it quite well to
begin with but she's doing it more
explicitly and also more within the
confines of
traditional religious conceptions
although she's not attending church
she's
associating with a number of people who
are formally religious and
all of that's informing the way that she
conducts herself
so it's watching her do that has
also highlighted for me
the missing praxis in
western christianity if you want to be a
christian
let's say if you think that's necessary
it's not exactly obvious what you should
do you should go to church
but that's not enough i don't think it's
she's been involved with um
well i think that's enough said about
that for the time being
i find it useful to contemplate
the highest good on a continual basis
that sounds so
i'm trying to keep myself oriented in
that direction it's a religious
orientation fundamentally
it's an overwhelming orientation
but there's no escaping the questions of
the ultimate meaning of life
i don't think
next set of questions how can
responsibility be differentiated from
imposed guilt
that's one question how can one
tell if one's inner voice judgment or
conscience
is a healthy one and not a voice that is
the result of an unhealthy mind due to
past experiences
how do i decide if my inner voice is
healthy or not and how do i maintain it
healthily now that's a really
interesting question it's a
question of conscience i continually ask
my frequently let's say
or yearly ask my personality class
attendees
if they heard the voice of conscience
if they had a feeling an emotion
emotional state let's say or of
voice that informed them when they had
done something
ethically wrong and that perhaps made
them
guilty as a consequence and it was
essentially a universal experience
that's the voice of
society within i suppose that's one way
of thinking about it
the freudians would think about that as
the voice of the superego
jung carl jung would take that
conceptualization somewhat farther
he would have considered it the voice of
the self
which is in part the voice
of the ethic that's derived from the
broader community
insofar as that ethic is valid let's say
but also in part the voice of the
more thoroughly developed self
that's still striving to be born one
thing you could say is that you
you experience violations of your
conscience
when you're not acting like the better
person that you could possibly become
and so to some degree that's your higher
self
upgrading you for failure to develop in
the appropriate direction
and that seems to me to be
a reasonable way of conceptualizing it
now the
one question might be how error prone
is your conscience given that you're not
omniscient and
i have an endless fascination with the
movie pinocchio
and part of that is because it taught me
something very sophisticated about
conscience in that movie jiminy cricket
is given divine attributes he has the
same initials as jesus christ for
example
and um
he is deemed the voice of conscience
itself
by by the magical properties of of
mother nature essentially
but in the movie it's necessary for the
puppet
who's still wooden headed and still a
marionette
whose strings are being pulled by others
it's necessary for the puppet to engage
in a dialogue with his conscience
because
both of them have to inform the other
and that seems to me approximately right
because
i certainly saw people in my clinical
practice and
no people in my private life who seem to
labor under a two authoritarian
labor under the dictates of a two
authoritarian
conscience maybe that's the internalized
voice of a relatively tyrannical father
for example
or exaggerated sensitivity to
the moral pressure exerted by the
broader social world
you have to attend to your
guilt and your self-disgusting your
self-contempt and
your self-consciousness you have to
understand that the manifestation of
those emotions
might well indicate a moral failing on
your part or a
a lack that needs to be addressed well
at the same time considering that
it is not a straightforward matter
to deal fairly with yourself and
you can be too tormented by your
conscience
too rigid too responsible
take on too much weight onto yourself
deny yourself in a manner that isn't
sustainable
and so forth that that a moral
code a moral way of being can become too
rigid
and and inflexible
and despite its putative aim upward
be something counterproductive i think
most of
the way out of that if there is one is
well careful thinking you have to see
what your conscience says you have to
see
how you respond you have to capture
that voice and your responses and you
have to think it through but
most of that is done in dialogue with
other people
rather than as the consequence of
internal thought
you know if you have a dispute with
your wife or your husband your intimate
partner sibling
your parents anybody close to you and
it's useful to for each of you in the
dispute to
ask yourself and the other person very
seriously
if you're at fault or if they're at
fault
and and for both of you to be able to
contemplate
that you might be at fault and so might
the other person and that it's in your
best interest to sort out exactly
who's made the error and where and maybe
it's both of you and maybe at different
levels of analysis
um i think the same might be said about
your reaction to your conscience it's
not
uncommon for me to talk to my wife my
kids my parents
my friends for that matter about
something i might be feeling maybe i'm
guilty about something i'm
self-conscious about something i'm
angry about something
i feel impelled by my conscience to do
something as a consequence
to change something uh
it's very helpful to discuss such things
with other people
to say look here's what i think i did
wrong and here's how i'm punishing
myself
but i'm not sure that i'm not doing it
in an exaggerated way and
you gather other people's opinions and
listen to them carefully and
are extraordinarily useful in that
regard and that can help you calibrate
it
so i think most of what we do to decide
if our inner voice is healthy is
discuss it with other people and i
believe as i pointed out in my last book
explicitly that tremendous amount of our
sanity is maintained
as a consequence of social interaction
so
you can't find your authentic self
merely as a consequence of
a journey within i would say you
you're not there's just not enough of
you you you have to be informed by the
broader social world
there's more about that too how can
responsibility be differentiated from
imposed guilt well
i think you adopt genuine responsibility
let's say healthy responsibility i think
you adopt that
more or less voluntarily i mean there's
an element of necessity and compulsion
in our lives as well because there are
things we have to do to survive but
if you've explicitly formulated a set of
goals
and you're pursuing them then you've
adopted the responsibility to act in a
certain manner to make those goals
realize themselves that's
that's responsibility that you've
adopted rather than
responsibility that's been imposed on
you assuming that you've thought through
the goals and you find your spirit in
harmony with those goals
you can consult your resentment i think
that's a very useful step if you find
yourself angry and bitter about the
things that you
are responsible for doing then
that's an indication that you might be
operating under some
unhealthy compulsion that you're
rebelling and that's the reason for the
resentment against
the insistence that you act in a certain
way
although it's also possible that you're
just immature and that
you're rebelling against the discipline
that's necessary to attain the goals
that you
genuinely do want to attain and that are
valid and that
you are what
actively engaged in constructing so
you have to get that straight and some
of that's a consequence of thought and
again some of that's a consequence of of
discussion with
other people with whom you're
intimate enough to have a conversation
like that
and perhaps they have conversations
about similar things with you if you're
fortunate
i'd love to get insight into why it
seems inevitable to become frustrated or
annoyed
with a loved one's chronic although
usually non-fatal illness symptoms
i'd love to know how even while caring
deeply for someone with a chronic
physical
condition it seems impossible to
suppress
what might even be anger while
witnessing them suffer
even minimally well
it's one of the terrible things that you
see
in any case of illness especially
chronic illness is that
the person with the illness is often
blamed for the problems that the illness
causes
and some of that's just difficulty in
differentiating between the person and
the illness
when my daughter was ill with rheumatoid
arthritis she had to sleep a lot
16 17 18 hours a day and
and even during her minimally awoke
times she was likely to nod off and
that made getting her to school and so
forth quite difficult and it was very
challenging to not
be morally judgmental about that when
she was a teenager
it's often difficult to get teenagers
out of bed it was just
very challenging to
differentiate the illness from the
person
and it's very helpful to have other
people around you
under such circumstances so that you can
discuss
the issue uh of course you can always
discuss it as well with the person who's
ill and we
i talked a lot to my wife about such
things and
and to my parents and also to my
daughter and to my son as well
all of us were trying to calibrate this
properly
her as well because she didn't want to
misbehavior to
the list of illness symptoms we we told
her
not to use her illness as an excuse ever
because then she wouldn't be able to
distinguish between what she could do
and what she couldn't do if she
if she used her illness as an excuse
that was a difficult job of
discrimination for her as well
and then i would say well you get angry
because
you're upset about the fact that the
world's unfair and tragic
so there's an existential level there
too is it's so
heart-rending and burdensome
to note that the universe is constituted
so that
people you love suffer unreasonably and
unfairly and
constantly and often without relief
and that anger
can easily imagine that manifests itself
as a general irritability that makes you
more susceptible to being angry
with the person who's ill and with all
the other people in your life and
with yourself as well with everyone
it's best to the degree that it's
possible to dispose of that generalized
resentment because
justifiable as though it might seem
it is not i've never seen
it be it to be helpful
shaking your fist at god is not a
constructive way of dealing with the
world
even though it does appear that there
are plenty of reasons why such shaking
might be justified
um it's not a place
that the human soul should go
and then the third factor that's
important i would say is that if you
find yourself angry
when you're in the position of chronic
caretaker
it's really possible that you need more
help
if you're dealing with someone who has
alzheimer's disease for example or any
chronic
degenerative neurological condition
or any chronic degenerative condition
in general there's only so much
you can do before you can't do any more
or even that much and it could be
assuming that you're reasonably well
constituted and
reasonable that you're
being called on to deliver more than you
actually can sustain across
time and two seriously ill people
are not better than one and so if you
find that you're resentful and angry and
and therefore lashing out at the person
you're taking care of
you might ask yourself whether it's time
to do whatever is necessary if that's
possible
if you have the luck and the resources
to
bring in more help if it's
if you're in it for the long haul it has
to be sustainable
and you can't ask yourself to
continually do
the impossible it has to be sustainable
and
you can have an honest discussion with
yourself and
although this is also something useful
to discuss with other people about just
what you can take without
breaking morally or physically or
emotionally
uh and for how long and if the
resentment is building and the anger is
building
maybe you have to change the manner in
which care is
being offered and
and given you have to hire a nurse you
if you can you have to rely more on
other members of the family you have to
consider
institutional intervention all of these
things are very difficult
you have to ask others for help but
like i said two sick people aren't
better than one so
those are the reasons why you might get
frustrated or annoyed with a
loved one's illness symptoms i think
i don't think it's a mystery at all why
you get
annoyed and angry the mystery is how
many
how it's possible for so many people to
engage in long-term care of others
without being angry and irritable that's
the that's the miracle
that's the mystery i've seen people
provide
levels of care to members of my own
family recently for that matter that
went far above and beyond what i
considered the
reasonable call of duty so and i would
say too don't torture yourself too much
if you find yourself
being angry or annoyed at a loved one's
illness
i i understand why you would think that
that's a terrible thing and it
it is in some sense but it's also
virtually inevitable for the reasons i
just described and
you do what you can to keep it under
control and
you also learn as clearly as you can
what you can tolerate and what you can't
so
in regards to your notion of the
importance of romantic relationships
i presume that also means long-term
committed relationships
what are the requisites for opening the
relationship to other sexual partners
well i i don't think that's possible
that might just be
conservative me um
i don't think i've ever seen it work
people and i think the evidence that it
doesn't work
is manifest in the fact that people
almost never do negotiate that openly
they
sneak around if they're going to have an
affair and the reason
they feel compelled to sneak around is
because they know perfectly well that
the probability
that their partner is going to grant
them wholehearted permission
and encouragement while simultaneously
maintaining the intimacy of the
relationship and the desire for it to
continue is virtually
zero um i think
a simple relationship is complicated
enough
it's very difficult to negotiate
intimacy with one other person
let alone a number of people
uh people might
wish that their sexuality
could find its free expression
untrammeled by the arbitrary
restrictions of a judgmental society
inappropriately disgusted by ashamed and
frightened of sex
but i think that's all most all
wishful thinking i would
put in the coda that i have seen people
in my clinical practice who were
too restrictive in their sexual morality
and that that was doing them harm
people from a fundamentalist background
who were in their mid-20s
with no partner
marital partner on the horizon who'd
never engaged in any sexual activity of
any sort
that on a case-by-case basis seldom
seemed to be a good
solution so
[Music]
but i don't think there's any evidence
that
at the personal and social level
simultaneously
and considering the long term as well as
the short term there isn't
any viable alternative to committed
monogamy
and wish that there were
is fantasy in my estimation and
generally counterproductive and
generally
very destructive so
now you know people differ and
highly open people who are
low in conscientiousness let's say by
temperament
perhaps low in agreeableness
this is all speculation might find
the possibility of open relationships
over some period of time
i'm skeptical i've never seen it work
not without a lot of lies and deception
of one form or another
not a lot not without a lot of
begrudging acquiescence on the part of
at least
one party in the negotiation you know
sometimes people will agree to something
that they don't agree to because they
feel it's the only way of hanging on to
something they truly value
so one partner might say well shall we
open up this relationship to further
exploration and the other
agree merely out of fear of losing
what they have that doesn't mean that
there's been a negotiated settlement
so i think there are no requisites for
opening a relationship
to other sexual partners
a set of questions again
i have been reading through carl jung's
work and more specifically his work on
integrating the shadow
what is the best way of integrating the
shadow in a person's life
without sacrificing their ethics or the
well-being of others
i am way too agreeable what steps can i
take to integrate my shadow
and stop being a doormat
all my life i've had so much anger but i
don't know towards what or how to get
rid of it
i've been through a few different types
of therapy and it's a bit better
but still takes me over from time to
time what advice do you have for me
i don't think that there's a better
pathway to the shadow let's say
than resentment
if you're feeling resentful about
something
there's a shadow that reveals itself in
two ways one is
it's a pointer to your immaturity
you need to be more disciplined you have
set
goals hypothetically and if you haven't
then you're under the sway of someone
else
or you're undisciplined and
unintegrated and incoherent which is all
shadow life in some sense you're
pursuing
short-term impulsive goals because you
haven't thought it through you're
pursuing goals that other people have
established for you
you're not pursuing any goals at all
because you're too nihilistic
to believe that life has any purpose all
that's
shadowy let's say um
but maybe you have set goals and now
you're resentful
about all the work that you have to do
in order to acquire those goals and
maybe that manifests itself as a
broad-scale critique of social structure
it's that's a maturity and so you can
delve into that and
you can find out where you're still a
spoiled child and
hopefully take action to rectify that or
you may find that
you're being compelled to do something
that
violates your integrity and
you need to stand up for yourself and
say something that you don't want to say
and
then you may have to learn how to
incorporate your anger
into your actions so that you
learn how to say no when you need to say
no
and so that actually means that you're
furthering your ethical pursuit as a
consequence of integrating your shadow
rather than deviating from it
aggression which can be repressed sexual
sexuality lust let's say which can be
repressed those things are extremely
useful servants when they're integrated
into
the hole if you're
without aggression and anger and
incapable of it
that doesn't mean that you're on a good
path and that
anger knocks you off it that can happen
but it's much more
appropriate and sophisticated to note
that
the probability that you're going to
pursue a higher good
is magnified by your integration of
all your emotional and motivational
states
even the ones that can cause a
tremendous amount of trouble when
they're left
to manifest themselves in isolation
you're way too agreeable well i would
say
you you could practice saying what you
really believe
that you can take a vow to tell the
truth
and that will make you much less
agreeable
agreeable people are perfectly willing
to sacrifice what they
know to be the case to maintain
short-term social harmony
and it's not so much that they repress
what they think it's often that they
don't even allow themselves to fully
realize what they think
so a commitment to the truth can make an
agreeable person
will stop an agreeable person from being
a doormat
i mean if you're in a relationship and
the person is irritating you with
something they've done
you might be highly motivated not to say
anything about it because you want to
keep the peace
you don't want to upset them you don't
want the conflict
that's all characteristic of
characteristic of high agreeableness
but once you decide to tell the truth
then if you're annoyed
you don't get to hide it you don't get
to assume you're right
you don't get to grab the person by the
shirt caller and say
look i'm annoyed and you're wrong you
get to say
uh i've i'm irritated about this
situation
and i need to think through that
irritation to find out if
i have a problem or if you have a
problem but there's or if we both have a
problem
or if it's a different problem
altogether but you can't
hide the fact that the problem has made
itself manifest
and so if you're agreeable
and you tell the truth about your
emotional state
that will propel you out of that
agreeableness by necessity
so
with regards to anger i don't know
towards what or how to get rid of it
well something a
cognitive behavioral therapist might
recommend is for a week
and maybe this is already a therapy
you've been through but
this exercise is generally quite useful
first you have to note when you're angry
and admit to that and maybe you have to
practice that so you have to decide i'm
going to
pay attention i'm going to see when i'm
angry and i'm going to admit to it
at least to begin with without judgment
i'm just going to observe it i'm going
to allow myself to observe it
then you have to allow yourself to
see what angry thoughts you have
and you can ask yourself that what angry
thoughts do i
frequently have they'll likely come to
mind
maybe many of them you can jot all those
down those are ones you're familiar with
and then you can notice when you're
angry and you can ask yourself well what
am i thinking
right at this moment what angry thoughts
am i thinking and some of them might be
quite shocking you might also manifest
themselves in destructive fantasies
you know maybe you have a fantasy of
grabbing somebody by a shirt collar and
pushing them up against a wall
or dumping you know hot coffee on your
boss or
some impulse towards aggression that
might manifest itself as a flashing
fantasy
and perhaps one that you're shocked by
and don't want to admit
you don't want to admit to the existence
of it but you need to see what's
happening first
in your own imagination if you're going
to cope with it and you also
it's also possible that a fair bit of
the anger that you have is actually
useful if you could just
find out what it is and what it's
directed toward
so the first
attack is to explore the anger
what gives rise to it what situations
give rise to it what people give rise to
it what are you doing when it happens
and
what is the phenomenology of the anger
how does it make itself manifest in
image fantasy and thought
and then now you have an anger
inventory is anger in this situation
warranted what steps do i have to take
in order to become less angry and
sometimes that might be an adjustment of
internal
an internal psychological adjustment
sometimes it might require changes in
the world
maybe you're in a relationship that's
oppressive and you have been for a long
time and
the way to fix that isn't to adjust your
attitude although it could be
but it might be that it's time to get
out of the relationship
and so differentiation
what when are you angry what elicits it
elicits it why are you angry
who are you angry at what are the nature
of the angry thoughts
what are the nature of the angry
fantasies all of that you have to get
that out
where you can see it and you have to
walk through it and
you can do that by yourself you can do
that while writing
you can produce counter thoughts so if
you're angry about something you could
outline the reasons why anger is not
productive or you could outline the
reasons why it's productive
and the reasons it's not productive for
a full exploration
of the issue so
then i would ask you too if you're angry
all the time is well are you depressed
have you been evaluated clinically if if
this is a major problem is it a
manifestation of depression because
anger is an under diagnosed symptom of
depression
um do do you have well thought through
goals and plans and strategies all of
that
that's a more comprehensive evaluation
of your entire life
and maybe you have something to say or
do that you're not saying or doing it's
highly probable most of us have that
problem
do you have sympathy for the left
politically particularly the marxist or
group identity focus
types i feel like the left has a point
and a lot of leftists
many leftists have their heart in the
right place even though they may
misguided
in some aspects of their thinking well i
have plenty of
sympathy for the left um
the left speaks when it's speaking
appropriately for the dispossessed
and there's a
unequal distribution of talents and
resources in the world
that doesn't mean that that's all a
consequence of inadequate social
organization but
it's nonetheless a painful fact and
people who are relatively powerless
let's say or who are relatively deprived
need their voice as well and the left
can do that
the the leftists that i've met who i've
admired were people who
genuinely had the
interests of the working class
uppermost in their minds and they were
usually trying to facilitate the ability
of
working-class people to move forward in
the world and to negotiate as well
rather than focusing their attention on
punishing the
hypothetical oppressors so
yes i have sympathy for the left i also
understand the temperamental
advantages of people on the left who
tend to be higher in creativity and
lower in orderliness they're more
entrepreneurial in their
essential orientation to the world
they're
more favorable to the free flow of
information at the cost of
the borders that divide things and
that's a valid
point because the free flow of
information has utility
even though borders and boundaries also
have utility
uh and so hence the utility of the right
um it isn't the left per se that i've
ever objected to it's
it's radical bitter utopians who
place evil somewhere that's convenient
for them morally and then have a target
for their unexamined
malevolence the same thing happens on
the right
so
of course the left has a point
you discuss almost any thinker's flaws
in their thinking except for
jung's what what were his
well i think jung
over generalized his experiences his
clinical experiences
he conceptualized the hero's journey as
something that was fundamentally
creative and interior
and i think that that's
probably true only for people who are
really high in trait openness who are
creative and i suspect that jung
attracted a tremendously
disproportionate number of creative
people to his practice
given the nature of his personality and
his interests
i found in my own practice that when i
had creative people
they were very inclined towards the
discussion of literary themes they
framed their life in literary terms
they were prolific dreamers very
interested in dream analysis
they enjoyed a literary approach to life
my more conservative clients often
equally high performing although i
had a practice that spanned the entire
range of of human
ability um they weren't
interested or captivated by that at all
and for them the
primary adventure of life wasn't
internal
or literary it was external and
practical and the more agreeable types
their life was primarily social
rather than symbolic or creative
they found most of the meaning in their
life as a consequence of
the uh intimate relationships that they
were able to establish
it wasn't infrequent and this was more
true of women than of men
and they are higher in agreeableness on
average
i i had conscientious clients who would
frame their life in terms of their
accomplishments
their career accomplishments that's how
they parse their life up temporarily
first i was in school and then i went to
university and i studied this and then
it was all extra it was all achievement
oriented
whereas the more agreeable types they
would say well
you know when i was 12 years old to 14 i
had this relationship
and then i moved to this relationship
usually the intimate relationship so
sometimes familial framed their life
that way
jung was an introvert was introverted
and highly highly open
and so that skewed his view in a
particular way and
then because he was psychoanalytic he
also
tended to view the psyche as
sane as a consequence of its internal
organization
and even its internal ethic and
placed much less stress on
the role of social interactions
and society as a whole in
producing sanity you know a sane person
is not only
organized internally but they're
integrated with their society and
the internal organization actually
reflects the social organization they
mirror one another
and there's although jung being a very
sophisticated person
of course knew that social adaptation
was necessary it was more his colleague
alfred adler who
const who was more politically on the
left by the way as well
who concentrated more on the
interpersonal aspects of life and
the role of socialization in the
maintenance
and and in and the maintenance of social
of intimate relationships say
uh in relationship to sanity
that's not stressed much in you if you
immerse yourself in the union world you
you'd end up convinced that we were all
creative religious mystics and that was
our
that was our essential destiny if we
were going to realize the highest
reaches of our being and
there's some truth in that but there's
also truth
in the proposition that you can find
your pathway
as an agreeable person in your
relationships or as a conscientious
person in your
duty
you know a union might argue that all
that still has to be nested in something
transcendent at the outer reaches of
personality and
i suppose that's possible but um
that's what i would say with regards to
the limitations of jung's thinking um
it's also the case that although he
identified
at least one of the major personality
traits extroversion
although the modern version of it is
somewhat distant from his original
conceptualization
he didn't notice that one of the major
personality traits was neuroticism the
tendency to feel negative emotion
he never formalized that idea in his
thinking and
it's a great oversight in some sense
because the
capacity to experience negative emotion
when that's exaggerated that seems to be
the core feature of
everything that we regard as
psychopathology
psychiatric and psychological illness
it's not the only thing but it's the
primary factor
so
what is the best way to avoid falling
back into nihilistic behaviors and
thinking
well a large part of that i would say is
is habit the the maintenance
the development maintenance of good
practices
habits if you find yourself
dissolute uh neurotic if your tenants
if your thought tends in the nihilistic
direction
and you tend to fall apart organizing
your
life across multiple dimensions is
a good antidote it's not exactly
thinking
do you have an intimate relationship if
not well
probably you could use one
do you have contact with close family
members siblings or children or parents
[Music]
or or people who are even more distantly
related if not
you probably need that do you see your
friends a couple of times a week and do
something social with them
do you have a way of productively using
your time
outside of employment are you employed
do you have a good job or at least a job
that
is practically sufficient and that
enables you to
work with people who you like working
with
even if the job itself is you know
mundane or repetitive or difficult
sometimes the relationships that you
establish
within in in an employment situation
like that can make the
job worthwhile um
have you regulated your response to
temptations pornography alcohol abuse
drug abuse
is that under control i would say
differentiate the problem
there's multiple dimensions of
attainment ambition
pleasure responsibility all of that
that make up a life and to the degree
that it's possible you want to optimize
your functioning
on as many of those dimensions as
possible you might also
organize your schedule to the degree
that
you have that capacity for discipline
do you get enough sleep do you go to bed
at a regular time do you get up at a
regular time
do you eat regularly and appropriately
and enough and not too much
are your days and your weeks and your
months characterized by some
tolerable repeatable structure
that helps you meet your
responsibilities but also
shields you from uncertainty and chaos
and provides you with multiple sources
of reward
those are all the questions that i would
decompose the problem into the best way
to avoid falling back into nihilistic
behaviors and thinking
how can you tell if the person you're in
a romantic relationship with
is the right person to spend the rest of
your life with
ah you can't you actually
decide that rather than discovering it
um i might say
what i might suggest what you might look
for
on the way to making that decision
all things considered a certain amount
of similarity
on the personality dimensions between
the two of you is
probably um
to be recommended if you're
if you differ tremendously in trait
conscientiousness one of you is going to
find the other
unbearably rigid orderly and
workaholic oriented and that person is
going to find you
dissolute and undisciplined and those
are temperamental differences and if the
gap is large it's hard to bridge it
agreeableness it's the same thing the
warmer person will find the colder
harsher person um cruel and
and unkind and the
cruel and unkind person will find the
more agreeable person
soft uh a pushover and
contemptibly unable to stand up for
themselves and
the extrovert will want to be out
partying all the time and the introvert
will have had
his or her fill of that very rapidly so
you want some temperamental similarity
across the major personality dimensions
with the possible exception of trait
neuroticism
which is the generalized proclivity to
experience negative emotion
i would suggest that a person high in
neuroticism
seek out someone low or very low
because if first of all neuroticism is
one of the best predictors of
unhappiness in a relationship and so
if you're both high in neuroticism
you're very likely to be unhappy in the
relationship and
it's highly probable that the higher
the person who's higher in neuroticism
needs the stabilizing influence of
someone who's
lower so then i would say well
this is based on my clinical
observations as well as my
the experiences of my life i think it's
necessary
or at least highly desirable that you
find the person that you're
with sexually attractive
and that's somewhat ineffable uh
you can be confronted with two people
who
are by objective standards equally
attractive and
or perhaps equally unattractive and find
yourself
very physically attracted to one of them
while the other one will leave you cold
and
that's a deep mystery and i've seen
couples
try who get along as friends try to
bridge that romantic
gap by will and
i haven't really seen it be successful
so i think you need that spark
that ignites sexual passion
then you have to ask yourself if you can
trust the person
if you can if there are activities that
you can
share with them that would make up a
life if you're oriented in approximately
the same direction with regard to your
goals especially important goals
career and children being foremost among
them
if you think you could come to some
agreement about how the economic
resources could be distributed
or at least how that might be negotiated
if you can negotiate with the other
person and
again if you can trust them and i would
say of all those
trust is the most crucial component
may be followed by the ability to
negotiate
the right person is someone you can
negotiate with because
there's going to be differences between
you and them there's going to be
differences in your approach there
should be
hopefully they'll be because that means
that the two of you are bringing
different skill sets to bear on the
problem that
means that you have a more diverse range
of potential responses which can be good
but also that there's going to be
conflict
the issue then becomes can you negotiate
through the conflicts
and will the other person stick to their
negotiated solution
and then if you find someone like that
and they're of approximately the right
age and
everything else seems to be in order
then
in some sense they're as good a bet as
the next person and
life doesn't last forever and so there's
real reasons to get on with it
so
it's it's you have to understand that
even in the best relationships
the best relationships are predicated on
attraction
trust and negotiation and it's
constant you're constantly negotiating
to to maintain the relationship
to expand it and
you don't find the right person and live
happily ever after
that life is far too complicated for
that
does the intellectual dark web exist
did it exist does it exist now
do you believe there is something that
has or needs to
emerge to replace it and with you back
to your normal self
such as that is what do you think the
idw members should be doing now
well i think the idw
was more did it exist well
i get parodied for saying this all the
time but
it depends on what you mean by exists
no in that the people who were
nominally part of that group had never
come together and said
we're part of a group yes
in that there was a web of
interconnected
social communications that were made
public
among an identifiable subset of people
who were active on youtube six years ago
five years ago uh so
it existed as a pattern of communication
or as a social network
an implicit social network and then it
was given the name
uh by eric weinstein
and popularized by barry weiss the new
york times
columnist at that point so it existed
as a social network that was named so
was observed and then named and then
popularized and then of course what
happened among us
who were deemed part of that was that
well we were flattered i would say
pleased at being recognized
pleased i would say as well to to be
part of that group
which was very intellectually diverse
on the religious front and on the
political front although i suppose to
some degree it tilted in the
conservative
direction but even that wasn't that
clear certainly sam harris and jill
rogan weren't
clear conservatives i don't think i'm
a particularly obvious conservative
all things considered either but
be that as it may why did
the idea catch on well i think a lot of
it had to do with
the the specifics of
revolution in communications at that
point
this group of us who were in contact
with one another
were in contact primarily through
youtube
and so we were all early
adopters of this space that
computer-mediated video communication
opened up for philosophical slash
political slash intellectual or
pseudo-intellectual depending on your
stance
discourse we were early venturers into
that
domain and there weren't that many of us
to begin with especially
that many in cross communication
and so the idw name
stuck in some sense because it did
give a terminology to an emergent
phenomena that was
new and different it was the development
of
the alternative media that has now
become widespread
that was oriented around long-form
conversation which is a revolutionary
concept
especially as well as revolutionary
technology
that you could engage in free-form
communication around a set of questions
or about a specific topic and
broadcast that publicly without any real
editing
without any real a prior restructuring i
still think that's completely
revolutionary
um so i think it the idw
did exist and then once we were named
that
increased the probability that we would
mutually communicate although
to some degree that's fallen apart over
the
intervening years partly because of
political differences between
members of the group but also partly
because it was a very loose
group to begin with
and each of us had our independent
existences that weren't predicated on
anything like a
centralized administration or
bureaucracy
so i still
communicate with many of the people who
were nominally part of that group
and i would say feel a certain amount of
affection
and certainly respect for all of them
regardless of how their opinions might
have differed from mine
i mean i had a sequence of conversations
that i felt
were highly productive
from the purely personal perspective
with sam harris and
was never obvious to me that i was
completely right
and he was completely wrong
these were very complicated issues we
were trying to hash our way through and
it was
certainly worthwhile to have made the
effort
and to have done it publicly and other
people seem to
also found that useful
what should the idw be doing now well
they should continue doing what they did
well and
many of them are brett weinstein has a
very good podcast and
um uh ben shapiro's media empire keeps
growing as he incorporates
cancelled people in i'm still producing
podcasts and writing
and i'm hoping that all of us
what we should do is what we and joe
rogan of course is
extraordinarily successful and
doing what he's doing and many and many
other people are doing the same thing
now and so what
what what is it that we're doing and
what should we be doing well we should
be trying to have
interesting conversations
the interesting conversations that this
new technology
make possible and to disseminate them as
widely as possible
we should also be to the degree that the
idw
was a cultural a countercultural
movement in some sense
well what we all should be doing and i
think are doing is
exploring the narrative space
the the narrative space of politics and
philosophy and spirituality to some
degree
we're we're trying to tell different and
hopefully
better stories and and to help other
people
enact those stories understand those
stories and enact them to the degree
that they find
useful and and so what should we
be doing well we should be trying to
make things better
and telling the truth while we're doing
so and
i do think that that was in the main
something that characterized
all the members of the idw is that they
were
committed to
the truth in their speech and in and in
their mode of being
in in their exploration and
i think that was recognized by their
audience members and depreciated i don't
think that stopped as
as well so there was an idw and there
still is to some degree but it's
expanded greatly there's so many people
now doing
long-form youtube interviews and and
podcasts that space has exploded and
and that's really good as far as i'm
concerned
um that's associated with another
question
how significant a role do you think
social media has played in the
disintegration of the political
discourse
in terms of how it enables people to
form echo chambers
and also for the social media platforms
such as twitter engaging in censorship
favoring
their vested interests well
social media i think has played a bigger
role in broadening the political
discourse and bringing it to
a much broader on bringing it to
bringing it to a much wider
audience and changing the way that
political discussion takes place
and youtube in particular and podcasts
and i think that's all to the good
uh political discussion no longer
comes in the form of discourse
uh generated from on high it's become
democratized and
i think that's better it looks to me
like it's better
i think the new media forms allow for
more
for deeper and more
precise truths
there's no bandwidth limitation you can
expand on ideas
indefinitely you can allow the
conversation to go where it will
you're rewarded for honest engaging
conversation
there's no administrative or
bureaucratic intermediation
i think that's all good it does face us
with the problem of what to do with an
overwhelming plethora of
ideas but there are worse problems than
that
i don't think there's any evidence that
social media has actually produced
increased tendency for people to exist
in silos
um i know that's a popular conceit but
the research that i've looked at
suggests that it's not
really the case that people are not more
they're not in a mirror chamber now as a
consequence of social media any more
than they were
when those four forms of discourse
didn't exist
in terms of twitter etc censoring
um well that's obviously a problem
i i so far it hasn't become a fatal
problem
and there are i think the
i'm hoping that the forces of innovation
and diversity
in terms of technological development
will always stay one jump ahead of them
of the more sensorious types
it's certainly the case that the idw
such as it is has not been censored to
the point of
that like threat although that has
happened in
in some instances
and i'm not trying to make light of that
i know it's an important problem but
i don't see that it's
a dire that the state is dire
um or more that i don't see that it's
irreversible
i think that this
opportunity for free dialogue that
the long form platforms like youtube and
podcasts allows
a very powerful counter force to
whatever sensorial tendencies might
exist
can i see a way forward from this that
is positive
sure you know i hope that people
and i'm trying to outline that i hope
that people
take responsibility at the individual
level that they
do what they can to orient themselves so
that they're working for the betterment
of things
consciously that and and note their
counter tendencies like i understand
that
because life is so difficult it's easy
to become bitter and cynical and to work
to make things better and
to find yourself facing something within
that's compelling you to do
precisely that it's it's it's it's part
of the
eternal battle between good and evil
that goes on in the human soul
it's not trivial but
you can attempt consciously to orient
yourself to the good and to tell the
truth and use
social media to facilitate
that and insofar as we're all doing that
things are going to be better rather
than worse i mean
i see quite frequently
on the comment section on my youtube
channel
when there's a particularly positive
discussion i had one with the cure the
dawn recently
that was marked for this and also with
chris williamson
and most of the others with russell
brand
this is happens to after virtually all
the conversations i have with people by
the way but
those three particularly
the comments and there's thousands and
thousands of them are all incredibly
positive even in
when when a comment is generating
replies
not only are the comments positive but
the replies to the comments are
in the main overwhelmingly positive and
so my
observation has been that if you engage
people in a meaningful
and truthful manner
about something interesting and
important and you explore that and you
bring them along for the ride
and you do that with respect and you do
that as part of the audience as well as
you know the voice from on high then
that's a very positive experience for
everyone who's involved
the discussants as well as the audience
members and that that all
pushes strongly against
malevolence and deceit and bitterness
and cynicism and corruption and
political polarization and
and all of that so that's the way
forward it's like
love and truth uh that's the way forward
meaning the pursuit of meaning
that's the way forward and there isn't
anything more powerful than
than that perhaps you could throw beauty
into the mix although it's not
so obvious how that's related to
you know a youtube discussion
specifically
i suppose there's elegance of speech and
cadence and rhythm and poetic
uh discourse and and that that's all
beauty
so yes there's definitely a way forward
be a good
person that's the way forward be the
best person you can
that's the way forward everyone knows
that everyone knows that
thank you very much and that's enough
for today